[Music]
a general reminder for viewers who wish
to approach Glass Onion with fresh eyes
kindly consider this your first and only
spoiler warning
[Music]
from the Twisted Mind of a director who
still checks Twitter and the streaming
service who's about to F around and find
out
comes a new Benoit Blanc mystery but
since you probably forgot his name get
ready for Glass Onion a Knives Out
mystery knobs out where I say where are
there any knives out in this feature
film
okay that's one
all right that's two Journey back to May
2020 right before America stopped caring
about kovid sorry coming up
and reunite with Benoit Blanc the
world's second greatest detective I'm
not Batman he can crack any puzzle in an
instant it was birdie
control the national press if I pulled a
few strings I could keep it from leaking
to the press and rock Breezy outfits
with a schwadaviv of a post bond Daniel
Craig
watch this deep fried Dandy get dropped
into the center of a blooming onions
worth of mystery who sent him the
invitation who is the mysterious Andy
who murdered Duke who fake murdered the
fake version of Andy who real murdered
the real version of Andy and Who has
possession of the red Netflix envelope
of shame in what seems like a deeply
layered plot but has a stupidly obvious
solution at the center the most famous
guy in the cast did it call it the Chris
Evans Corollary
leave your worries behind and join a
corny Tech Mogul on his private sex
Island Elon Musk I mean miles Braun he's
got horrible taste horrible ideas child
equals nft and horrible friends grab a
hard kombucha Jared Leto send him over
like Kate Hudson's birdie she's a nepo
baby but you know one of the bad ones
Catherine Hahn as herself you really
make an effort well I figured Greece
Dave Batista as a men's right streamer
by reality
excuse Mom sorry who shows more emotion
in his head grooves than the rock does
in his entire face Lionel a scientist
with zero personality but covers for it
by dressing like a high Beast is that a
salvage denim lab coat swag and of
course A Who's Who of people with
nothing going on when Kobe shut down all
live sports and theater even Joseph
Gordon-Levitt had time to toss a little
dong in there
what is that that's the hourly dong but
what's a good mystery without a femme
fatale and Janelle Monae delivers twice
the femalities she'll play Helen a woman
searching for her sister's killer and a
convincing Alabama accent hail who's A
working class icon in that she gets
better at her job when she's got a
little buzz going
maybe you should take a drink and you're
just killing it and she'll also play
Helen's identical twin Andy a girl boss
who started a scammy crypto company
refused to change her business to clean
energy I can't let you do this gathered
all these horrible people together in
the first place and Miles was leader of
the pack no Andy was they were all
friends with Andy and never shared a
dime with their own family this rich
people is weird so we got Justice for
the evil twin
so break out that pen and pad for a
mystery that you're never going to solve
the first time through because you
probably gave Ryan Johnson more credit
than using secret Twins and bulletproof
journals but you should know what to
expect from this franchise by now smug
Rich a-holes you can smugly look down on
one non-a-ho woman of color who takes
all their money and Status away and a
second half that's a virtue expectations
of everything that came before yep
that's right he last Jedi's his own
movies in his own movies The Madman it's
so dumb
so dumb it's brilliant story
when you learn what Ben was last name
means what Monet Lisa guile Norden
futilities almost blame us
you have a Google alert for the word
movie I like movies don't he one of us
one of us Colleen winging it it wasn't
Agatha all along men in Blanc and The
Big Lebowski nice try Daryl those are
white russian mixers in your room can't
hide for me
dial ass for shed
you know if Benoit never took the case
Maz would have blown up his own
spaceship and power plant plus the shed
friends would go down too Mona Lisa
didn't have to catch a stray like that
wait it's not over there's another
trailer in this trailer that's a Twist
worthy of oh M Night Shyamalan visit the
servant Community here on fandom to
explore discover and dive deep into
every detail of servant
people keep getting hurt in this house
so yeah when she's happy things are good
when she's angry things go bad
I'm not who I used to be
something like more if she wins the
setting will fall and that's only the
beginning
[Music]
Duke don't dance with pineapple
2023 will be freaking legendary New
Year's same epic voice trailer guy my
New Year's resolution is to keep reading
these dumb comments there is a tempest
in me for I have returned from Taco Bell